in chapter 907 of one piece we first
learn about an Infamous pirate called
rockste zabek and since that chapter
we've learned that he not only tried to
take over the entire world but that he
was also the captain of a crew that
included three future Emperors of the
sea and so in this video we're going to
explain everything that we know for a
fact all the hints about his past and
even some incredible speculations about
his true purpose in the story now since
we don't really know a whole lot about
rocks it is important to clarify and
clearly explain what is fact or close to
fact and what is speculation and to do
that we're going to break up all the
information about rocks into six
categories and in each category discuss
what we know and what we can speculate
starting with a brief introduction of
his character in chapter 907 Luffy's
grandfather Monkey D GARP first revealed
that the Rocks Pirates ruled the Seas 40
years ago which is about 14 years before
Goldie Roger became the first pirate
king Garth tells a young group of
Marines that if the rocks Pirates were
to reform then they would be a threat
beyond what any of them could possibly
imagine and then 50 chapters later the
former Fleet Admiral sengoku reveals a
boatload more about rocks and his insane
crew for one we learned that the world's
government considered rocks to be their
biggest threat and it took an
unbelievable effort to stop him from
taking over the entire world which we
will of course discuss in more detail
later on and so let's dive into what was
probably the most strong pirate crew in
the history of One Piece ever here are
the facts on this ridiculous crew were
three future Emperors of the sea the
strongest creature in the world kaido
the monsters mother big mom and former
strongest man in the world's whitebeards
now besides these three powerhouses we
have Shiki who was a former rival of
Rogers and in addition we have this old
lady Miss buckin who was part of the
crew before she then joined the science
group math that was founded by vegapunk
then we have silver ax complete mystery
Captain John who had a famous treasure
that buggy was looking for died and then
unfortunately God reanimated and turned
into a zombie on Thriller bark by Moria
and finally there was Wang zi also known
as ochoku and while we don't know a
whole lot about ochoco we do know that
he ruled over the Rock's Pirates former
base Island until he was defeated by
Blackbeard and of course we cannot
mention a pirate crew without also
discussing their ship while we don't
have any other information about it you
can see that this is a quite large
vessel and pretty damn intimidating now
let's shift to discussing the
relationships of this wild crew because
it is unlike anything that we've seen in
the story so far because in chapter 957
sengoku revealed that the cruise Dynamic
was horribly toxic The Rock's crew
members would regularly fight and
sometimes even kill each other a bit
what is even more interesting is that we
can speculate about the crew's
relationships from all the other Clues
sprinkled throughout the story first of
all Whitebeard seems to have had a very
negative experience on rox's crew his
reaction was kinda like a boss you hate
to work for in chapter 964 Whitebeard
initially refuses to let the samurai
Odin join his crew because Whitebeard
had a bad experiences with his own
previous crew which was most likely The
Rock's Pirates and from this we can
assume that he has a lot of resentment
from his time on rox's crew since it is
still bothering him decades later it
seems like Whitebeard has learned that
having too many strong-willed
personalities on one ship might destroy
a crew this also supports sengoku's
claims that the crew was in a state of
near constant chaos which looking at all
the members makes a lot of sense another
fact is that big mom did not seem to
trust rocks at all either in chapter
1041 during a flashback we see that
kaido has just joined the Rock's crew
and big mom tells kaido that if he
needed anything he should count on her
because rocks was not trustworthy and so
from this all it seems that rocks did
not lead by inspiring trust and loyalty
as it seems that many of them did not
even like him in the slightest bit and
this mistrust had the ultimate
consequence for rocks when the crew
later abandoned him as we'll discuss in
just a second now if this is true then
we have to wonder how exactly rocks
keeps this crazy crew together in the
first place and so let's now shift over
and dive into everything that we know
about Roxy's back as a person as well as
his powers and history of course
starting with the fact that he is dead
maybe even though sengoku tells us that
Rox is dead the circumstances of his
mysterious disappearance make me believe
that that is not all that we've seen
from such an important character and
let's compare this situation to an
equally famous dead Pirates the
execution of Roger is the first scene in
the entire story and while we don't
learn a lot more about Roger until much
later on his influence is present all
throughout one piece and the entire
world from his former crewmates his
Rivals and even the fact that we found
clues about his journey along Luffy's
path however while Rox was pretty much
an equally and probably even more so
powerful and influential figure as Roger
was we did not learn anything about him
for over 900 chapters and so that kind
of makes me think that one he is either
still alive and going to play a role
later on in the story or two he is dead
but we will get a huge reveal about his
past in the upcoming arcs previously on
the same channel we have even discussed
the possibility that he might have been
Luffy's other grandfather or another
theory by the Creator arter that
speculates that he could actually be the
secret ruler of the world right now in
other words emu after all taking over
the world was rox's goal in the first
place and these two characters were
introduced so close together in the
story but whether he is dead or secretly
still alive we can reasonably assume
that he seems to have been evil we do
know that GARP and Roger both of whom
are quote unquote good characters try to
stop him from achieving his goals also
Whitebeard clearly didn't like him and
the world government considered The
Rock's Pirates terrorists and so
whatever his true intentions were maybe
they were good but in the end it is very
likely that he seems to have committed
some truly terrible acts in the pursuit
of his dreams and what were his dreams
well we were told by sengoku that rocks
was ambitious and his dream was to be
king of the world and damn that is a
title that we've basically never hurt
anyone use before not only did he want
to become pirate king like Luffy it
seems that he truly wanted to dominate
and rule over everyone and everything
and he almost succeeded which again we
will discuss during the final battle
later on and this leads to another
really interesting question can someone
be king of the world without being
insanely powerful after all we do know
that it took both Roger and GARP teaming
up together to defeat rocks and he was
considered the former Pirates King's
greatest rival so clearly he was a
extremely strong fighter now we do know
that rocks used a sword as we are shown
in this scene here in the silhouette and
even kaido considered rocks to be one of
the few Pirates who could give him a
true Challenge and since we also know
that kaido big mom and Whitebeard all
had conquerors hockey extremely strong
one with that it makes a lot of sense
that their former Captain would have all
these extremely high levels of hockey as
well now this is speculation but his
conquerors hockey could have also been
on a completely different level since he
was able to command all of them and this
is even more supportive because his main
goal was to be king of the world and if
that's not the spirit of a legendary
conqueror then I don't know what is now
one thing that we do have no details
about is if rocks actually had a devil
fruit now there is no mention of such
power so it is completely possible that
he did not have a devil fruit similar to
Roger Shanks or guard or he might have
had one and we just haven't been told
yet another possibility that we can
speculate about is that Rox was
patiently waiting to get the right devil
fruit sounds like anyone familiar and
that rocks was basically finally going
to get that devil Feud during the
legendary battle on God Valley and
alongside his powers Rox was deeply
curious about the true history that we
do know sengoku tells us that he broke
many of the world's taboos and that he
was erased from history because of that
sin and we all know that that can just
mean one thing it means that he was
researching the pornoglyphs which are
these unbreakable stones that tell the
true history of the Void Century now
throughout the story researching the
pony glyphs is the only reason the world
government has erased a whole group of
people such on the island of Ohara and
as they're trying to do to the
government scientist Dr Vega Pang in the
current Arc and this allows us to
speculate that either rocks himself
could read the pony glyphs or that he
knew someone who could now this idea
opens up a whole new Avenue for theories
for example one interesting Theory
centers around the mysterious three-eye
tribe which was first mentioned in
chapter 853. that was during the whole
kick island arc where we meet big mom's
daughter pudding she was born with a
third eye meaning that her father must
have been from the three I tried now
according to big mom people from this
tribe naturally possess the ability to
use the voice of all things though in
Putin's case she seems to not have
awakened that power quite yet now in
case you're wondering this mysterious
power allows certain people to hear the
thoughts of animals such as the sea
Kings and even vaguely understand the
words on the phonoglyphs but now you
might be asking how does big mom know
about this tribe in the first place
these are all speculations but a simple
though unlikely answer is that she could
have randomly found them on an island
somewhere out there in the world but
we've never seen this tribe anywhere
else before and only very few people
seem to even know that they exist in the
first place and so another and maybe
more likely possibility is that rocks
himself was from the three-eye tribe or
that he had someone on his crew who was
as well this would of course explain how
he could research the history of the
white Century since only two people are
confirmed to be able to read the pony
glyphs right now kaido also knows of the
secret ability of the three eye tribe so
he could have also learned it from rocks
as he was on the same crew and it would
also make sense that they learned about
the poniglyphs and the true history from
rocks as well since we're never told
that either of them travel to lodestar
Islands that's because in chapter 820 we
are being told that it is on Roadstar
Island that a person is supposed to
First learn about the pony glyphs but
moving back to some facts rocks was also
a member of the Declan people who have
this initial such as Luffy Blackbeard
and dragon are said to be the enemies of
the Gods of the celestial dragons so it
would only make sense that he was also
likely a very charismatic leader similar
to Luffy and he's somehow convinced all
of these strong Pirates to come together
to make one big score and that's one big
score seems to have been taking out all
of the celestial dragons on the
legendary island of God Valley and you
can also Land one big score by
subscribing to the channel to receive
more videos just like this one so let's
now finally discuss what happened on the
legendary island of God Valley and the
legendary battle where rocks was finally
defeated first we know that 38 years ago
the Rocks Pirates attacked a mysterious
island that was inhabited by Celestial
dragons this event has been covered up
by the world government because
basically no one in the world knows
about it except for people who were
there or some of the higher up and more
older Marines part of the reason that it
was covered up is the fact that rocks
could only be stopped by an alliance
between a much younger GARP and Goldie
Roger before he became Pirate's King and
honestly if you can imagine it what a
clash this must have been rocks Roger
Whitebeard GARP big mom kaido
all our Sensei show us more of this
legendary fight please and while we know
next to nothing about the actual battle
or that Island itself which has vanished
completely from the maps we are told
that GARP and Roger defended the
celestial dragons and their slaves who
wear on that island huh but part of this
does not make any sense you see we know
that Garb hates the celestial dragons
and he has even refused to become an
admiral specifically because he doesn't
want to take their orders so we really
have to wonder why he and specifically
Roger saved the celestial dragons and
God Valley there are a few options and
the last one will probably completely
blow your mind but first of all the
easiest possibility is that Garb simply
protected the slaves on God Valley
certainly that would fit with garp's
character another interesting option
that I've theorized about in a separate
video is that GARP Roger and rocks were
all once on a little crew together
before Rock Swan power crazy and Garb
joined the Marine so perhaps GARP and
Roger felt that it was their duty to
stop rocks before he did something
insanely evil as their former comrades
however the final option was that there
was something else on God Valley that
GARP and Roger could simply not allow
rocks to take or get his hands on but
what could this magical treasure be uh
maybe but no in all seriousness it is
actually highly plausible that the world
government's devil fruits were kept on
God Valley and that this is what Rox was
after all along I do go into a lot more
detail and then a lot more evidence of
this theory in my specific video on that
but let's briefly discuss the topic here
the idea is that devil fruits are the
source of the magical powers in the one
piece world so obviously they are
incredibly valuable we know that the
world government likes to gather devil
fruits such as the opeopenomi and that
government's agents can sometimes get
strong devil fruits such as when these
two secret agents were giving their
devil fruits and endless Lobby and so
the question becomes what if the
government have a large store of devil
fruits or even a devil fruit tree itself
that used to be on God Valley and while
this is a theory and speculation there
is actually a lot of evidence to support
that for example in chapter 999 big mom
reminds kaido that she gave him his
legendary dragon devil fruit on the same
day as the battle on God Valley where
the Rock's Pirates fell to ruin wouldn't
that suggest that she found it on God
valley during the chaos of the battle
similarly we do not know where
Whitebeard got his legendary trauma
fruit which is said to be capable of
destroying islands and even the worlds
we never see him use it until after the
god Valley incident so what if he also
found his fruit during that battle and
remember when we said that rox's toxic
crew Dynamic would surely come back to
bite him well it is interesting to see
that every member of rox's crew
abandoned him at God Valley what if this
crew who didn't really care about their
Captain got their strong devil fruits
and then just left it also goes along
with the idea that The Rock screw was
formed to make one big score so once
they all had their own powerful devil
fruits and fulfilled their plan the crew
didn't really care to stick around
because they had all fulfilled its
purpose and if this is all true we have
to imagine that Rox was after his own
immensely powerful devil fruit as well
so that he could take over the world and
I do know that we're at this point
really deep into Theory territory but
let me make one last connection before
we get back to things that we actually
do know for a fact because if Rox was
seeking a devil fruit to help him
conquer the world wouldn't it make sense
that he would want the strongest one
possible well we're told that many
people consider a certain devil fruit to
be the most dangerous ability in history
and that is the darkness fruit which was
eaten later by blackbeards what if Rox
was seeking this fruit on God Valley
specifically and he didn't fail but that
he actually got the fruit and into the
world before he died or disappeared
forever and so now let's shift to
Blackbeard because out of any character
in the story he has by far the most
direct connection to rocks in the story
at the moment here are the facts
Blackbeard named his own ship the saber
of zebek a clear reference to roxyzebec
the two Pirates also appear to have the
same method of building Crews based
solely on strength and kind of getting
something out of it for everyone for
example Blackbeard gathered a large part
of his crew by having prisoners fight to
death and then only taking the strongest
survivors and rox's crew was well known
to fight each other as well also both
Crews seem to have a large number of
devil fruit users and Blackbeard has
ensured that most members of his crew
have a devil fruit as well with rox's
crew we don't know if all of them had
devil fruits but Whitebeard kaido and
big mom all eventually got overpowerful
devil fruits and Blackbeard also cares a
lot about dreams and wants to conquer
the world just like Roxy's back they are
also the only mem members of the D Clan
who appear to be outright evil hell even
their smiles are eerily similar they
have also both made this island their
home base this island has many names
including beehive hachinosu or simply
pirate Islands this is where the Rocks
Pirates originally were formed and after
the crew disbanded it was taken over by
the former rocks pirates ochoku that man
was ruling hachinosu until then
Blackbeard claimed the Islands during
the time Skip and coincidentally this
incident also involved Marine vice
admiral Kobe and was called the rocky
Port incident and while we don't know
ochoku's exact Powers he must have been
strong because Blackbeard said that he
only was able to overthrow ochoku due to
the assistance of Luffy's friend and
Marine vice admiral Kobe during the
rocky Port incident and Blackbeard
hasn't changed much since he took over
that island with partying and drinking
all around it is truly a lawless pirate
paradise and while Blackbeard now
currently rules this island there is
some room to Theory rise that buggy the
clown may eventually make an appearance
on the island as well how you ask well
remember that buggy has long been
chasing The Treasure of the former rocks
pirate Captain John in chapter 233 we
see buggy searching for the treasure on
an island with an enormous skull and
while this turned out to be the wrong
island with our giant skull hachin also
also has this giant skull as well so
wouldn't it make sense that Captain
John's treasure was still on the island
of the former rocks Pirates and so this
could eventually lead buggy who is now
an Emperor as well to that Island as
well and who knows maybe at the end of
the story this could be Buggy's home
base but enough of buggy let's get back
to Blackbeard with all of the
connections between him and rocks let's
explore their relationship a little bit
further we already discussed how rocks
could have previously wanted
Blackbeard's devil fruit a common theory
within the community is that rocks
actually ate the darkness fruit and his
soul is still living inside of that
fruit now before you call me crazy let
me explain the darkness fruit is said to
be a strange fruit compared to every
other devil fruit it doesn't work like a
typical logia fruit as it absorbs all
attacks instead of being unaffected by
Common attacks as it should be also one
of the main powers that we see
Blackbeard use to suck everyone in is a
black hole if it can suck in people and
buildings it isn't that much of a
stretch to think that it could also
contain a soul so could Blackbeard
actually have a piece of rocks inside of
him there is some evidence that this
could very much be possible we have
multiple references of Blackbeard
possibly being multiple people Marco the
Phoenix claims that he has a very weird
body which might be the reason why he's
able to eat two devil fruits Luffy and
Zoro mentioned that he could be more
than one person and after a battle
apprentices buggy the clown and Shanks
discuss how Blackbeard is rumored to
never sleep although this occurred
before Blackbeard ever obtained his
Darkness fruit and this could mean that
he has multiple personalities that come
awake while the other ones are asleep
now whether or not this is true there is
certainly some connection between these
two characters it could be that
Blackbeard is somehow related to rocks
as Blackbeard was born two years before
the god Valley incident another option
is that Blackbeard inherited rox's will
after reading a journal or something
like that left behind by rocks and that
he's now trying to achieve Rock's dream
sometime in the future and speaking of
the future Roxas influence will
undoubtedly impact the story later on if
he's still alive he will surely show up
to be a true obstacle for the straw hats
or if he is actually dead we could learn
a lot more about him from many different
characters the upper Tia Marines like
Garb senguku or the commander-in-chief
Kong should certainly know a lot more
about this character and Shanks and the
other Roger Pirates could know about
drugs as well and certainly big lemon
kaido know about him if they're still
alive the five elders and emu should
also know exactly exactly what happened
to rocks and even buggy if he were to
ever find Captain John's treasure could
Discover Real clues about this
mysterious figure and I can't imagine it
at the same time that we found out more
about Roxy's back we will also find out
even more information about the most
mysterious and influential character in
the entire series Joy boy much like
Luffy and Blackbeard are basically
opposites The Joy boy from the void
century and rocks appear to have
opposing roles in the story Joy boy
brings Liberation while Rox wants to
conquer and rule the world and this
insane connection will undoubtedly
influence the future of the story so who
is joyboy and what do we know about this
figure from the void Century if you want
to find out you can watch this video
right here thanks for watching